but first it's my brain dump
well i was planning to start tonight's
show with the impending report on
illegal lockdown busting parties in
downing street which is finally due any
day now feels like we waited longer for
civil servant sue gray's report than the
sequel to top gun but now it's here
looks like it could be every bit as
explosive but in the last few hours
sensational photographs have been
published by itv news which in my view
render the report well frankly
superfluous it's now pretty clear that
boris johnson hasn't just lied to the
british people in the media he's also
lied to parliament here's a clip of
boris johnson in parliament last
december he was asked a direct question
about a specific party the prime
minister tell the house
whether there was a party in downing
street on the 13th of november
mr speaker no but i'm sure that whatever
happened uh the guidance was followed
and the rules were followed at all times
well we all just heard him right i mean
he said very clearly
when he was asked was there a party on
november the 30th no
he said that to parliament to the
country and he said the rules were
followed at all times but the photos
published tonight
show him at a party on november the 13th
leaving drinks held for johnson's former
spin doctor lee kane now remember the
time the country was in its second
lockdown pubs were closed gatherings of
two or more people were banned yeah here
is boris johnson the prime minister the
man who made the rules a glass raised in
toast bottles of booze and party food on
the table
and there next to him a government red
box with all his prime ministerial
papers what was in that box more details
of new pandemic lockdown laws for the
rest of the british public to obey
boris johnson was always very clear
about obeying the rules
mr speaker we expect everybody in this
country to obey the law right expect
himself right
apart from him and all his staff at down
history it's not very clear that a lot
of people in the corridors of power of
number 10 downing street led by the guy
at the top ignored their own rules and
broke the law boris johnson attended
illicit parties and then he lied about
it and we now also know that two weeks
ago he had a secret meeting with sue
gray the very woman charged with
investigating him and his staff
and when the meeting was exposed the one
they hadn't bothered to tell us about
downing street briefed it was all her
idea
then today downing street admitted
actually
it was their idea so they lied again
about a meeting that boris johnson
wanted with the woman investigating him
just before the report comes out am i
supposed to believe this is an
independent report
well sue gray must now publish the
report in full including every one of
the 500 photographs of parties he said
to have collected let the public judge
with our own eyes
and make up our own minds because
tonight one thing is crystal clear about
partygate we can't trust a word that
comes out of a downing street frat house
about this whole tawdry affair
we're talking about affairs prince
andrew continues to shame the british
establishment he was rightly stripped of
his honorary titles and the designation
of his royal highness in public after
settling a civil sex abuse case out of
court for a reported 11 million dollars
the payout for virginia dufrey who
claimed the prince assaulted her when
she was 17 made no admission of guilt
but andrew had said he was determined to
fight the case to the end and clear his
name
and then he just caved and wrote a big
fat check that decision obliterated his
reputation and heaped embarrassment on
his mother the queen and it tarnished
the monarchy severely too it should have
been the end of andrew as a public
figure but it seems literally just a few
months later he wants to come back
the queen remember banned him and the
sussex from the buckingham palace
balcony at next week's jubilee
celebrations and that looked like he was
being frozen out but incredibly
the comeback seems on first he emerged
center stage at prince phillips memorial
riding with her majesty the queen and
then walking her into the abbey while
all the world was watching now reports
over the weekend say he'll appear
alongside the queen and garter day one
of the most important raw ceremonies of
the year he'll be listed on the formal
royal court circular and dressed in full
regalia as an official royal knight
the grotesque irony of andrew starring
on a day designed to honor chivalry
won't be lost on his accuser nor should
it be lost on any of us
it's frankly a disgrace that he will be
going to that event at all that alone is
a royal night it will cause more
humiliation for the queen more damage to
the monarchy he should be barred from
attending
well the english football season reached
a thrilling conclusion this weekend but
the final few days of action were marred
by a series of horrendous attacks by
so-called fans yesterday aston villa
goalkeeper robin olsen was smack three
times as manchester city supporters
invaded the pitch to celebrate winning
the title
he just let him three goals in five
minutes to give them a trophy you'd
think these witless morons would be
chanting his name in delight not
attacking him
last tuesday a boozed up thug
head-butted sheffield united's billy
sharp as forest fans charged the pitch
to celebrate making it to wembley for
their playoff final
two days later crystal palace manager
patrick vieira was abused and goaded by
foul-mouthed everton supporters filming
the entire thing on his own phone vieira
eventually kicked out at the yard
prompting calls him to be investigated
by authorities but why he never backed
down as a player why should he back down
to a sniveling little coward hurling
spittle at him
there's been a steady depressing
increase in this kind of incident since
pandemic restrictions were lifted
current punishments clearly aren't
working as a deterrent and the bottom
line is if these pitch invasions
continue remember it is a criminal
offence to go on the pitch at all
then we're going to see a player or
manager get seriously injured or even
killed
i would find every single pitch invader
from this day on 20 000 pounds each with
immediate effect and give them a 20-year
ban from all football matches that might
sound draconian but what other option is
it
the party has to be over for these pitch
invaders because they
have already ruined the party
well viral news now it's not covered or
monkey pox but a rare outbreak of common
sense
at the heart of the british government
officials have overturned an attempt to
introduce gender neutral language in a
new law that would have replaced the
word mothers with expectant people
new guidance has now been issued to
ensure future bills will use gendered
words that well correspond to the gender
whoever they're talking about that old
chestnut this is a rare victory in the
woke war on words which is apparently
designed to avoid upsetting a tiny
minority whilst constantly enraging the
majority tomorrow we have the attention
of those in the corridors of par about
this issue here's my uncensored guide to
snowflake syntax and some other words
i'm pretty sick of hearing about
trauma this used to be something you
suffered in a car accident or after a
life changing event now apparently we
have hidden trauma racial trauma gender
trauma collected trauma trauma healing
trauma survival trauma bonding
it's all trauma is it you can dislike
something without being traumatized
the other one's violence you know this
one physical force intended to hurt
somebody right like those football jobs
attacking players but not anymore
history is now violent silence is
violent words are violent but they're
not are they
violence is violence
phobia used to mean something it was an
extreme fear
of things now it just means someone says
something you don't like
it's not islamophobic for example
because i don't like women being forced
to wear head-to-toe coverings it's not
transphobic if i say women are adult
human females and not menstruating
persons
having a phobia means you're scared
the only thing i'm scared of are these
over sensitive snowflakes destroying our
language